voilà c'était quand les entreprises
jouent à cache cache un documentaire
auquel vous pouvez réagir bien sûr sur
le hashtag docu débat un documentaire
réalisé par vous pierre oscar lévy merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés jean
arthuis bienvenus vous êtes député
européen président de la commission des
budgets du parlement européen membre de
l'ue dei ancien ministre de l'économie
et des finances en face de vous karine
berger bonjour vous êtes député
socialiste membre de la commission des
finances secrétaire national ps à
l'économie
et enfin vincent drezet bienvenue vous
êtes fiscaliste et secrétaire général du
syndicat solidaires finances publiques
bienvenue à tous alors on revient
d'abord sur ce documentaire commence à
vous est venue cette idée de
l'optimisation fiscale
c'est simple j'ai précédemment j'ai fait
un film sur l'état de la planète et plus
même dont la moitié du film c'était sur
la crise des subprimes et donc c'est
j'apprends j'essaye de comprendre des
choses je me suis dit qu'il y avait
vraiment quelque chose d'important à
travailler sur toute l'économie offshore
tout le toute l'économie qui en dehors
de des règles et il ya un certain nombre
d ouvrages qui sont sortis à ce moment
là j'ai travaillé sur ce à quoi et j'ai
eu la chance que d'avoir un producteur
christophe carrère qui m'a dit il faut
imposer un film à 35 qu'est ce que tu
veux faire et donc c'était le choix du
sujet voilà combien de temps ça vous a
pris une enquête est compliqué
d'enquêter sur cet univers là alors le
le reportage que çà çà çà çà prend la
forme d'une enquête
et c'est s'est fait par un journaliste
et c'est que c'est pas très compliqué à
faire c'est juste trouver le trouver une
manière de raconter avec des personnages
moi je suis pas compétent en terme de
décoration mais à partir du moment où on
avait une chaîne de personnages qui et
puis des gens qu'ils prêtent qui
préparent des lois etc
on avait on pouvait le faire et on l'a
suivi l'enquète ça a été de suivre ce
qui se passait au jour le jour
et donc on monte on tournait en même
temps ça c'était assez amusant
est ce que vous êtes heurter à certains
obstacles vous causer des surprises
les seuls obstacles qu'on pourra voir
c'est le sais que ça a été long à ce que
la chaîne se décider heureusement
monsieur cahuzac est rentré dans
l'actualité c'est tout d'un coup c'est
devenu c'est devenu intéressant mais
vraiment ça a été liée pendant très
longtemps le dossier n'était pas
suffisamment et puis après ça il ya une
vague de une vague d'émissions et c'est
la loi mais non ça appartient pas de
l'eau tout d'un coup ce ça monte en
termes de m en termes d'intérêts on se
dit que le spectateur va regarder parce
qu'ils en ont entendu parler de ça
qu'est ce que vous vouliez montré en
particulier c'est une certaine
impuissance des politiques face aux
multinationales ou est-ce que c'était
montrer l'idée qu'une crise fiscale
était peut-être plus forte que la crise
financière
non enfin moi ce qui m'a demain
m'intéressait c'est de comprendre
comment est ce que ben il y avait autant
d'évasion fiscale ou et qu' il y avait
si peu d'argent qui rentre dans les
caisses de l'état c'est à dire que
réellement le projet du film c'était de
se dire nous on est pour les impôts il
faudrait que les impôts rentrent de
manière à ce que à ce que l'état fasse
son travail
alors après on a chacun des idées
personnelles mais quand on fait un film
documentaire c'est quand même pour
expliquer un certain nombre de
mécanismes de donner la parole à tout le
monde et essayer de comprendre ce qui se
passe moi je suis un étudiant je
travaille à chaque fois je suis fier je
le rentre dans un un des tas de domaines
j'adorerais faire un film sur verre
simenon peu comment ça fonctionne
il ya un certain nombre de films qui
pourrait se faire à la suite de face il
serait fort série qui s'amorce
non ça ne souffre pas rien ce
documentaire karine berger ben je pense
que le documentaire est très utile pour
montrer à quel point on est face à un
problème à la fois français mondial des
groupes multinationaux qui refusent
refuse de payer
leurs impôts là où ils font du profit
l'eau ils gagnent de l'argent c'est de
fait qui refuse de participer à l'effort
commun
je prends toujours cet exemple c'est
vrai que depuis le documentaire total a
annoncé qu'il allait enfin commencer à
payer d'impôt sur les sociétés en france
on attend toujours parce que c'est pas
encore fait mais messi total vendée de
l'essence et que tout le monde fait en
france et que tout le monde faisait
comme total ne payait pas ses impôts et
bien il n'y aurait pas de routes en
france donc totale voudrait voir de
naissance à des voitures qui ne
bénéficieraient pas de route parce qu'on
n'aurait pas les impôts pour payer les
routes voilà c'est l'absurdité de ce qui
est montré dans ce dans ce dans ce
documentaire qui est aussi est très
technique et je crois que c'est ça qu'il
faut absolument continuer à travailler
politique
genre tu vos réactions je trouve ça un
documentaire très intéressant
il faut bien voir que la fiscalité est
national et l'économie est devenue
globale mondiale et les états sont en
concurrence les uns par rapport aux
autres et chacun cherche à attirer sur
son territoire des entreprises pour y
créer des emplois pour y payer un peu
d'impôts c'est ça qui est évident donc
la fin de documentaires dit mais au fond
l'impôt sur les sociétés est mort il
faut un impôt mondial maintenant il faut
organiser le monde
on n'y est pas et moi qui suis député
européen je constate que la
fragmentation de l'espace européen est
un encouragement à à l'optimisation
fiscale puisque les puisque les taux
d'imposition varient d'un pays à l'autre
la fragmentation est une aubaine une
rente pour tous ceux qui vont exercer
leurs talents dans la parfaite légalité
c'est pas c'est pas si simple alors il
ya le discours politique qui est
imprégnée de générosité mais qui devient
vite et devient cas cités qui était qui
n'était pas la générosité devient très
vite confronté à la réalité et il suffit
pas d'avoir des idées généreuses parce
qu'au fond plus l'impôt est élevé plus
on a intérêt à imaginer des exceptions
des exonérations des déductions
moi je me souviens j'étais
istres à l'époque et j'avais dit il faut
baisser le taux marginal d'impôt sur le
revenu des personnes physiques et j'ai
reçu des lettres de tous ces gens qui
font qu'ils font office de conseil
fiscal de d'optimisation fiscale vrai
mais vous n'y pensez pas si vous
réduisez le taux de l'impôt marginal nos
arguments de ventes s'effondrent parce
que nous plus l'impôt marina est élevé
plus nous sommes convaincant pour
essayer de vendre de la défiscalisation
pour des investissements dans les
territoires d'outre-mer pour
l'immobilier que sais-je on a fini par
imagine et entêtant de niches fiscales
qu'on n'y comprend plus rien les
contribuables non plus on voit fleurir à
la télévision à la radio dans les
journaux des publicités pour payer moins
d'impôts c'est pas des publicités de
leurs reportages faits et à un moment du
jour on a défendu en hémicycle des
amendements sur luttant contre l'évasion
fiscale pour l'anecdote qui restera
quand même extraordinaire le matin même
j'avais reçu un appel sur le téléphone
portable d'un cabinet de conseil qui me
proposait de d'échapper à l'impôt je ne
sais pas si je pense qu'il ne sait pas
d'où il avait trouvé mais mes
coordonnées je pense qu'il n'avait pas
tout à fait réaliser que j'étais député
à ce moment là c'était peut-être lié à
mon ancien travail mais c'était
extraordinaire
la bergère n'avez-vous pas voté
récemment une disposition pour exonérer
d'impôt les événements sportifs mondiaux
j'ai voté contre monsieur arthuis voilà
merci beaucoup pour me pour m'avoir posé
cette question fait partie non seulement
le disais permanent merci beaucoup
d'avoir ces questions j'ai partie des
députés qui non seulement ont voté
contre ce cet article qui était logé
dans une des lois de finances mais j'ai
même déposé des amendements pour
démontrer l'absurdité de la chose en
proposant d'exonérer d'impôts le
festival de cannes le congrès
international de mathématiques qui a
lieu tous les quatre ans le costa le
salon du bourget et cetera talent et si
on est si on exonère d'impôts les
événements sportifs mais exonérons napo
tout le monde y compris les événements
les jeux
on est trop loin sont susceptibles de
s'implanter ailleurs que chez soi et on
n'est passé que le congrès international
de mathématiques doit rester à jamais
sur sur les seuls contribuables qui ne
peuvent pas délocaliser fils marc et des
vacations
heureusement le sujet ça fait donc
plusieurs mois que les états unis
l'europe ont déclaré la guerre à
l'optimisation fiscale et aux
multinationales
c'est pas un phénomène nouveau pourquoi
maintenant pourquoi tout d'un coup c'est
une prise de conscience politique
économique
voilà c'est une prise de conscience
économies parce que les montants en jeu
sont beaucoup plus importants il est
notamment étrangers attaqués aux
particuliers précédemment avec
l'interdiction de secret bancaire nous
avons plus simple les particuliers que
les entreprises
parce que les entreprises jouent sur un
phénomène très complexe qui est ou où se
créent la valeur
c'est abstrait c'est à dire ce ne sont
pas des fins en deux et prônant
l'expliquera mieux que moi ce ne sont
pas des flux d'argent qu'on voit sur des
comptes en banque
si les constructions de répartition de
valeur et ce phénomène qui a toujours
existé avec les fameux gaza c'est à dire
les grands groupes américains de
l'internet ça prend une ampleur qui fait
qu'on va bientôt considéré que peut-être
la moitié de l'économie américaine n'est
plus susceptible d'être soumise à
l'impôt sur les sociétés ce qui serait
catastrophique vincent drezet
il ya deux choses qui joue en ce moment
c'est que déjà la situation globale au
sein de l'union européenne mais au delà
en termes de finances publiques est
préoccupante donc il faut trouver des
ressources
on a augmenté les impôts et lui
certaines dépenses mais tout ça une
limite et on s'aperçoit que d'un côté
d'optimisation mais également la fraude
parce que l'optimisation il faut
rappeler que c'est légal on verra sur le
fait que c'est souvent illégitimes et la
fraude représente un manque à gagner
colossal et puis il ya une dimension qui
est surtout plus importante c'est
l'acceptation des populations on voit
bien que en france notamment le
consentement à l'impôt et s'affaiblit
parce qu'il ya toujours le sentiment de
payer trop de ne pas avoir le retour de
ne pas être responsable d'une crise mais
de voir que par ailleurs des
contribuables j'entends pas
contribuables également des entreprises
notamment des grandes entreprises
légalement et légalement pmoi est donc
ce phénomène et
très importants notamment lorsqu'on est
dans une république une démocratie
puisque le consentement à l'impôt c'est
le pire c'est particulièrement important
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
depuis quelques années quand même eu une
prise de conscience
à défaut d'actes concrets et efficaces
etc il ya quand même une prise de
conscience je veux dire par là il ya une
dizaine d'années parler des paradis
fiscaux c'était réservé à un cercle
d'initiés parler de taxe les
transactions financières par exemple par
les conflits de réforme fiscale
d'harmonisation fiscale européenne
c'était utopique s'était jugé utopique
il ya quand même une prise de conscience
sur le fait que des choses était
techniquement faisable et j'allais dire
même politiquement souhaitable alors
avec selon les sensibilités des uns des
autres
aujourd'hui on constate quelques jours
le parlement européen a encore dit il
faut aller vers l'harmonisation fiscale
de l'impôt sur les sociétés il ya cinq
il ya encore cinq ans s'était jugé comme
un horizon lointain
donc ce qui est intéressant c'est que
parce qu'il ya un problème budgétaire
parce qu'il ya un problème jaillir
politique de temps en temps de crise
démocratique
on s'interroge j'ai à dire sur le
système simplement c'est extrêmement
compliqué effectivement il ya trois ans
on légalisait der packaging de ds dei
dans les paradis fiscaux des titres
subordonnés à durée indéterminée à
l'initiative de société nationale
contrôlée par l'état et le gouvernement
c'était en 92 j'étais rapporteur général
du budget pour sauver la face pour
préserver le ni ni à l'époque
eh bien on re package est des titres
dans dans les paradis fiscaux dans une
dimension de concurrence fiscale et
sociale et je me souviens avait hurlé
comme important général du budget aucun
commentaires médiatiques sur l'intérêt
de personne dans ce que vous dites sur
le la volonté de démocratique là quand
on regarde ce documentaire on s'aperçoit
que la morale puisque l'optimisation
fiscale est légal les multinationales se
retrouve dans une espèce de jeu un peu
pervers qui est ce qu'on fait n'est pas
très moral mais c'est légal
et on s'aperçoit que la question morale
prendre la place dans la question
fiscale mais le problème c'est la morale
ou si la loi le problème n'est pas la
morale le problème n'est pas la morale
je suis très mal à l'aise avec
l'utilisation de ce terme en droit et là
c'est ce qu'on vient le dit le rapport
droit il existe une ligne rouge
ninon jaune je sais jamais l'expression
exacte qui s'appelle l'abus de droit qui
est évoqué dans le documentaire qui est
le moment où on donne l'impression de
respecter le droit
mais en fait on le viol est cet abus de
droit et en angleterre par exemple
beaucoup plus largement sanctionné qu'en
france parce que la tradition de
juridique de tous les pays anglo saxons
permet justement d'aller débusquer
l'abus de droit et de revenir à l'esprit
du législateur en france ce qui pose
problème ce qui bloque c'est qu'on est
dans un endroit écrit et que à ce stade
la butte droit est quasiment inutilisé
je croise offert ma part qu'il ya eu
quatre ou cinq recours en un but droit
l'année dernière sur l'ensemble des
problématiques l'impôt sur les sociétés
sur les entreprises c'est à dire
quasiment rien donc on est bel et bien
sur une problématique de commandes ya
d'applications juste de ce qu'est la
volonté du législateur
que l'on soit rapporteur du budget en 92
on conçoit députés de la commission des
finances en 2015 ce qu'on dit dans
l'hémicycle devrait être beaucoup plus
strictement utilisé par l'optimisation
fiscale le but de l'optimisation fiscale
c'est de contourner la loi
bon je vais payer moins pour payer moins
d'impôts oui mais dons pour payer moins
d'impôts comme il est montré dans le
documentaire on a affaire à des
conseillers pour les pousser le plus
loin poussée de loin ainsi impôts et
payer là où on constate le bénéfice
alors chaque état a imaginé des
législations pour essayer d'alléger on a
optiquement des taux relativement élevé
mais derrière vous avez des crédits
d'imposer des déductions pour ceux ci
pour ça c'est une extrême complexité et
il s'agit de quoi il s'agit alors pour
les entreprises
il s'agit de constater le bénéfice
imposable
là où les taux sont les plus faibles et
pour les états il s'agit d'attirer sur
son territoire des entreprises et alors
c'est un marché extraordinaire c'est une
rente formidable pour les avocats
conseil en fiscalité qui sont bien
souvent d'ailleurs des anciens
d'administration vous pourrez désormais
vous pouvez retrouver dans un an dans
deux cabinets spécialistes mais des gens
qui ont commencé leur carrière à bercy
où elle est en général des impôts c'est
une évolution assez classique
un exemple très concret pour que tout le
monde voit à quel point entre le moment
où on essaye d'utiliser la fiscalité
pour inciter on peut basculer
immédiatement dans l'évasion fiscale en
france il ya une mesure qui est une
mesure qui à être plutôt été amplifiée
par la droite ne vont pas s'en séparer
sujet droite gauche qui est on a le
droit de déduire les intérêts quand on
est une entreprise on a doit 3,2 déduire
les intérêts d'emprunt de son impôt sur
les sociétés à 100 % ce qui était le
régime le plus favorable de toute
l'union européenne
résultat toutes les entreprises qui
faisait du lb haut c'est à dire en fait
de l'emprunt pour consolider leurs
structures à rapatrier
d'où d'ailleurs les investissements
directs étrangers très élevé en france à
rapatrier la partie endettement de leurs
bilans en france pour renvoyer sur
l'allemagne ou sur la république tchèque
la partie créa production ça partait une
bonne volonté l'idée de permettre aux
entreprises qui en propre qui empruntent
pour investir de da payer moins d'impôts
c'est une belle idée on a l'impression
que ça suffise à l'investissement
résultat il y en a certaines qui ont
fait n'importe quoi et qui ont utilisé
ça uniquement pour éviter tous les
régimes particuliers mais c'est un
exemple génère instantanément de
l'optimisation par exemple exonérer les
heures supplémentaires fait que le
directeur des ressources humaines va
transformer les augmentations de salaire
en heures supplémentaires pour échapper
à des cotisations sociales
là on focalise sur l'impôt sur les
bénéfices des sociétés
mais dites vous bien que l'optimisation
se perd dans tous les secteurs et plus
le prélèvement obligatoire est élevé
plus on est tenté de rechercher
l'optimisation pour les dans la ligue et
un respect de la loi payer moins
d'impôts ou de cotisations sociales
alors un moment dans le documentaire
vous le dit karine berger si ça ne va
pas il faut changer la loi alors est-ce
qu'il faut changer la loi
notre système fiscal qui finalement n'a
pas beaucoup été retouché depuis un
siècle le permet-il on devrait écouter
un extrait du documentaire
tout ceci est légal
c'est légal et donc si les politiques
sont pas contents mais il faut qu'il
change la loi et je trouve qu'il ya un
peu trop de facilité à dire ah ouais
c'est pas moral
ab en gros ces salopards une entreprise
ils respectent pas les règles parce
qu'ils n'ont qu'une éthique en réalité
non il utilise des instruments légaux et
s'il y en a qui ont pré fait leur
travail c'est plutôt les gouvernements
et peut-être nous aussi avons laissé les
règles dérivés si c'est légal et qu'on
n'aime pas le résultat
il faut changer la loi alors je vous
vois je vais réagir d'abord vincent
drezet
ce que ce que dit pascal saint-amans il
renvoie aux états tout simplement parce
que ce sont eux qui par le parlement
vote la loi
au passage on pourra donc s'interroger
sur le phénomène de concurrence fiscale
y compris sur la souveraineté est ce que
nous avons les budgétaires et fiscales
et cette souveraineté elle est entamée
pas ce qu'est une concurrence fiscale
la question est est ce qui aurait une
volonté politique de surmonter ça de
retrouver en effet pourquoi pas
européenne par l'harmonisation fiscale
delà l'europe c'était dur parce que le
problème c'est que l'optimisation
fiscale c'est l'utilisation effrénée de
des instruments légaux pour réduire
l'impôt
quand ça du canton franchi la ligne
jaune est bien rentrer dans le domaine
de la fraude sauf qu'on en vient à des
situations aujourd'hui ou des
entreprises ne payent pas d'impôts en
france ne paie pas d'impôts ailleurs ça
s'appelle la double non impose donc à
l'automne dernier les chefs d'état du
g20 puis leur ministre des finances en
février on conseille le cd une mission
changer les 3000 conventions
internationales fiscales qui permettent
aux multinationales de délocaliser à
leur profit légalement le cd v a
préconisé 15 mesures qu'est ce que ça va
changer
jean arthuis je pense que ce sont des
bonnes intentions mais avec la fiscalité
ondes et on est au coeur de la
souveraineté en tout cas de ce que
croient les états les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement je pense que nous sommes
dans la globalisation et au fond est ce
qu'il n'ya pas une réflexion à faire sur
l'impôt payé par les entreprises et les
impôts payés par les citoyens
moi j'ai tendance à dire que l'impôt est
toujours payé par le citoyen c'est ce
que je ne connais pas je ne connais pas
d'entreprise qui puisse dispenser de
répercutée dans le prix des produits
quel on met sur le marché qui seront
payés par les consommateurs les
différentes cotisations sociales les
différents impôts qu'elles auront eu à
payer donc cette idée
politiquement magnifique qui consiste à
dire qu'il ya d'accord les impôts vont
augmenter mais il y en aura une partie
payés par les citoyens et une partie par
les entreprises donc par les patrons
c'est vraiment un abus de langage ont
parlé d abus de droit il ya aussi des
abus de langage car l'impôt est toujours
payé par le citoyen est dans une
économie qui se globalise je pense qu'il
faut que pour le moins on essaie de
mettre un terme à la concurrence fiscale
et la concurrence fiscale est lié aussi
au fait que certains états mettent en
recouvrement plus d'impôts que les
autres
et là on paie plus d'impôts on est moins
tenté d'aller s'établir investir et
créer des emplois
c'est bien ça la difficulté et je pense
que la fragmentation de l'espace est un
atout formidable pour les fraudeurs et
pour ceux qui recherchent l'optimisation
par conséquent pour mettre un terme à ce
frag
cette fragmentation grâce au fédéral
isaac l'europe et je m'étonne que l'on
n'aille pas plus franchement vers un
partage de souveraineté en matière
fiscale
karine malric moment là nous aurions de
l'équité alors écoutez monsieur a reçus
dans ce cas la prochaine fois que le
parlement européen à l'initiative de la
commission des finances propose par
exemple de rendre transparent et public
l'ensemble des comptes des filiales des
grandes entreprises vous voterez pour ce
qui n'a pas été le cas lors de la
directive lorsqu'il n'a pas été le cas
de votre vote lors des directives ou ça
a été soumis porté par monsieur lambert
ce député européen vous parlez de
logement dal l'udc 6
et oui tout à fait une commission basque
a fellow c d e
le black est bête ce paquet bébé ça
donne par exemple parmi les quinze
évolué évolutions que vous évoquez
l'idée que oui il faut rendre
obligatoire la publication de toutes les
filiales toutes les grandes entreprises
publication qui permet de savoir combien
on a deux personnes qui travaillent de
profil c'est ce que vous dites c'est la
transparence et en quoi la transparence
doit permettre d'agir concrètement à ce
qu'à ce moment là monsieur de rosé qui
travaillent
bercy pourra voir si oui ou non le
profit
la dame est excusez-moi laisse-moi
jussieu direct il n'ya rien à voir
quelles sont les résolutions qui sont
des des intentions bercy et tous les
ministres ministère des finances de
l'union européenne et du monde verront
si oui où nous starbucks fait en fait
vendu café en australie mais en fait
rassemble ses profits aux bermudes c'est
exactement ce qui est en train de se
passer n'est donc pas par l'ondé on se
faire puisque c'est tout le point par le
wi fi liale une femme qu'on ne dépendra
pas forcément ce qui a été ici parce que
la loi nous la loi permet dans ce cas là
si vous arrivez à démontrer que le café
est venu en australie mais que le profit
et est présenté au bar mais la loi
française en tout cas permet
effectivement de corriger la loi
française permet bel et bien de congé ce
qu'elle ne permet pas de corriger et là
je me retourne vers monsieur arthuis
c'est quand ça se passe à l'intérieur d'
union européenne vous pouvez du fait de
la liberté de circulation dans l'union
européenne
vous ne pouvez pas au nom de la loi
française corriger une répartition des
profits d'où la taxe est sûre irlandaise
mais si vous le faites de manière
éhontée aux bermudes
eh bien oui la loi française le père
mais dont la transparence qui est la
première recommandation de l' ocde dans
son paquet baisse c'est là la clé
d'entrée de l'intégralité de ce qu'on
appelle une mécanisation de respect des
princes andrew et puis vous pourrez
repartir
moi je pense que la question la
transparence est évidemment importante
vallée même fondamental puisque
aujourd'hui les états ne connaissent pas
ne connaissent pas julien le chiffre
d'affaires le bénéfice réel des grands
groupes tout simplement parce qu'il est
logé via ce qu'on appelle les prix de
transfert dans des filiales situées pour
la plupart dans les paradis fiscaux pour
faire court et à tel point c'est que
quand on prend le commerce mondial de
ces deux estime que plus la moitié du
commerce mondial ce sont des
transactions intragroupe qui passent pas
les prix transfert il suffit qu'une
infime partie de ces pelés transfert
soit manipulée et c'est le commerce
mondial lui-même qui est destiné à tel
point que même ce la lecture libéral
c'est le jeu de la concurrence qu'il
faut c'est donc il faut de cette
transparence là mais cette transparence
évidemment c'est le permet dans les
administrations fiscales de mieux
contrôler
alors encore des progrès à faire il faut
effectivement passés par des obligations
déclaratives c'est pas quelque chose de
très lourd pour les entend plus
puisqu'elles ont déjà ces données là il
faut donc passer par un ensemble
d'informations mais ça permettra aussi
de mettre un coup d'éclairage sur ce qui
ne va pas dans dans la loi est ce qu'au
fond c'est ça si on reste sur le terrain
de l'optimisation on continue à le lire
à perdre de l'argent et cette question
de la répartition de l'impôt la
légitimité des politiques fiscales reste
posée mais surtout il a raison de dire
qu'il ya beaucoup de mesures
dérogatoires qui qui font l'objet
d'optimisation sûr mais encore faut-il
s'interroger sur l'efficacité sur
légitimité sur l'impact que ça sur la
redistribution des richesses
ensuite il faut s'interroger au niveau
de l'union européenne des projets
existent en matière d'harmonisation de
l'impôt sur les sociétés de la tva qui
sont quand même les deux grands drapeaux
et optimisé et forêts et 1,2 point et
l'on peut attendre des états et du
parlement et de la commission européenne
un peu d'avancé puisque c'est le moment
et à avant d'arriver sur l'union
européenne sur vous pariez de la
mondialisation tout à l'heure et son
impact on peut se demander à travers
cette aggravation du phénomène si
quelque part
l'impact direct de la mondialisation sur
les finances publiques n'a pas été
sous-estimée ces dernières années mais
par ailleurs et bien sûr mais de même
façon que le problème auquel je termine
ma question si vous faire une telle jean
marty l'arrivée des géants du net ce
sont aujourd'hui les géants de
l'optimisation fiscale
est ce que l'économie numérique a
contribué à aggraver le phénomène de par
sa nature dématérialisée et est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui notre système fiscal qui
n'est pas du tout construit pour être
efficace sur ce genre de modèle
économique ne doit pas être profondément
réformée bien sûr bien sûr le problème
va être de savoir à quel moment on peut
appréhender l'assiette et prélever
l'impôt dans une économie qui se
dématérialise quel moment une activité
taxable est précisément alors moi moi je
pense que taxer la production c'est
prendre le risque d'organiser la
délocalisation et donc la montée du
chômage et je pense que les vrais impôts
sont les impôts de consommation peut
assez facilement appréhender la
consommation l'impôt sur le revenu des
personnes physiques qui réside sur un
territoire qui sont membres d'une
communauté humaine et l'impôt sur le
patrimoine pour le patrimoine qui n'est
pas délocalisable
mais pour y parvenir
il faut qu'au sein de l'union européenne
on se met d'accord et camps fassent
converger dans législation pour éviter
ces avantages compétitifs lié à la
législation fiscale et là on a du mal et
est ce que j'observe alain berger c'est
que quand il faut désigner le président
de l'eurogroupe au groupe est en quelque
sorte coeur la construction européenne
et tu pourrais être l'embryon du
fédéralisme européen et bien qui va-t-on
chercher on va chercher le ministre des
finances puisque c'est ce sont les
ministres des finances qui sont membres
de l'eurogroupe
on va chercher celui qui est dans un
pays avec le triple à parce que ça fait
plus sérieux quand même
et on est d'autant plus facilement
triple à qu'on fait du tax ruling c'est
à dire qu'on fait un tas d'exonérations
davantage et donc on va chercher
successivement le luxembourgeois est
quant à lui que jean bourgeois s'en va
on va chercher le néerlandais ils sont
les champions de l'assistance google ne
paie pas l'impôt en europe pourquoi
parceque ils sont certes en irlande mais
ils transfèrent arrivé en transfert 4
milliard et demi de dollars sur un
chiffre d'affaires de 11 milliards de
dollars
il transfère à quatre milliards et demi
aux bermudes pour ne pas payer la peau
sous forme de royalties
alors si ça partait directement de
l'irlande vers les bermudes
il y aura une taxe spéciale et paient
donc ils sont organisés pour que ça
passe par les pays bas et les pays bas
sont complices de ce système
donc les européens eux mêmes devrait on
a vu les scandales avec le luxe leaks je
crois que maintenant il faut il faut il
faut arrêter il faut que les européens
comprennent qu'à ce petit jeu ils vont
perdre leur substance et l'agilité
qu'est ce qui vous manque pour ça
pourquoi on n'y vient pas là le problème
c'est le rapport de force politique
entre au sein même de l'union européenne
et avec certains pays on a vu que les
états unis quand ils ont voulu imposer
le à l'ensemble du monde y compris aux
suisses la remontée directe d avoir des
informations bancaires de leurs
concitoyens sur les états unis ils ont
obtenu en l'espace de six mois à peu
près en six mois ils ont tapé du poing
sur la table c'est rentré nous on attend
toujours de se mettre d'accord entre
européens c'est-à-dire notamment avec
nos amis luxembourgeois
en ce qui concerne la
mersen physique sur cette question là
donc c'est un rapport de force il y à un
certain nombre de gouvernements au sein
de l'union européenne qui à ce stade
refuse de voir que par exemple l'irlande
et le luxembourg
alors surtout en fait dans matière
d'impôts sur les sociétés
les pays bas parce qu'effectivement rien
n'est possible en termes d'optimisation
fiscale d'évasion fiscale en europe sans
le passage par les pays bas c'est à dire
la consolidation des holdings au niveau
des pays bas le système est
malheureusement déjà bien connus donc
oui on a un vrai problème de rapport de
force politique
je ne sais pas trop quoi vous dire c'est
que commençons déjà par balayer devant
notre porte en france et c'est un
exemplaire qui fait que les autres le
fonds devrait envahir revient à un tout
petit peu plus tard dans les bas vous
disiez il ya un instant jean arthuis
vous n'êtes pas pour un impôt sur la
production
pourquoi c'est le système que les
américains ont adopté certains
économistes prônent ce système là c'est
pas système idéal mais en tout cas il
serait plus réaliste
vincent grenier c'est tout débat on a
déjà vu que monsieur arthuis sur
l'incidence fiscale qui payent l'impôt
alors on peut effectivement partir du
principe que par exemple s'agissant de
l'impôt sur les sociétés il sera
répercutée sur des agents économiques
par exemple sur les ménages
encore faut-il savoir lesquels est cela
que c'est intéressant de le creuser la
question lorsque vous imposer le
bénéfice d'une entreprise alors supposer
que ce soit le bon bénéfices parce
qu'effectivement il a encore fauté sur
l'assuré donc ce prélèvement peut peser
également sur le versement de dividende
ordinaire que la fim et aux actionnaires
donc on a vu ce que la financiarisation
d'activité faisait s'il est
intégralement répercuté sur prix à la
consommation alors les faits mais le
sera globalement neutre par rapport à la
tva il peut également peser sur les
choix interne à l'entreprise sur les
mises en réserve l'investissement donc
il ya un débat intéressant sur
l'incidence fiscale mais il faut partir
de la réalisation du chiffre d'affaires
puis de bénéfices voir comment quelles
incidences à la pause les sociétés il
n'est pas totalement intégralement
répercutée dans le prix de vente est
donc c'est ça qui est intéressant parce
que si je pousse à l'extrême
votre raisonnement se serait de dire
privilégions la tva sur tous les autres
en attendant patiemment à tva les impôts
de la position de la consommation ou des
revenus il passé si vous tâtez la
production y compris donner une prime à
ceux qui produisent hors du territoire
national et qui viennent sur le marché
avec leurs produits qui n'ont pas
supporté les mêmes contraintes
il n'y a que la tva qui permet de
rattraper la différence mais la société
n'est pas un impôt sur la production
l'imposture et csc est un impôt qui
m'est fait un pas très important parce
que c'est un débat et on est entraîneur
que l'impôt sur les sociétés pourrait
être réformé vers un impôt sur la
production est ce que c'est une bonne
idée ou pas oui mais attention parce
qu'une partie de libéraux aux français
je me rappelle très bien de monsieur
madame explique en long large et en
travers que l'impôt sur les sociétés
c'est un impôt qui allait directement
sur la production c'est faux l'impôt sur
les sociétés c'est effectivement à
l'impôt sur la valeur ajoutée
c'est-à-dire qu'ils taxent tout autant
le travail que le capital ce n'est pas
le capital qui est axé avec l'impôt sur
les sociétés c'est le travail et le
capital et donc c'est pour ça que c'est
un impôt intelligent vraiment
intelligent qui fait en sorte que
l'ensemble de la création de valeur
participent à l'effort commun c'est pour
ça qu'il faut pas l'euro montait plus
haut au niveau de la production c'est à
dire de fait au niveau du capital
il faut pas le descendre plus bas c'est
à dire au niveau de la consommation il
ya un dysfonctionnement aujourd'hui
puisque aujourd'hui l'impôt sur les
sociétés s'applique essentiellement sur
les bénéfices et que les multinationales
déclare 0 bénéfices en france
oui mais le problème c'est le deal
structurelles interne de l'impôt des
sociétés
ce n'est pas la faute de l'impôt sur les
sociétés c'est la faute de choix
politiques complètement assumée d'un
certain nombre d'états qui justement ont
tenté de déplacer le curseur de manière
via les niches dit autrement s'est passé
vous déplacer l'endroit vous prenez le
prélèvement que vous ne créez pas quand
même une forme de concurrence et le
voilà à charrier pour capter la matière
imposable
ils pensent qu'en imposant - ils
attireront plus facilement sur leur
territoire des investissements pour
créer des emplois et faire de la valeur
ajoutée
donc cette espèce de concurrence que se
livrent les états pourquoi disneyland on
le rappelle dans votre documentaire
pourquoi disneyland est il venu en
france c'est parce que à l'époque le
gouvernement que préside laurent fabius
a fait du taxol inc c'est à dire que on
a expliqué à disney que si vous venez en
france ils paieraient moins d'impôts
qu'ailleurs et on a trouvé les mesures
particulières donc tout le monde fait du
texte une autre histoire sur disneyland
mais ça c'est un outil fixe puis quel
texte rowling parce que c'est
fondamental et dans la sphère du christ
on l'a vu le texte rowling en français
c'est le rescrit fiscal c'est un accord
qui est passé entre une entreprise et
l'administration sur un montage et sur
ces incidents
discale dès lors que c'est validé pour
une certaine durée en général cinq à
sept ans le montage ne peut pas être mis
en cause par l'administration fiscale
sauf s'il est vraiment détourné et c'est
l'ampleur de ce genre d'accord notamment
au luxembourg qui a mis en évidence
évidemment bien sûr cette espèce de la
morale nous plumer sur la légitimité au
fond c'est à dire qu'on avait un appeau
enfin un système fiscal qui est déjà
l'objet de certaines critiques et en
plus de scènes au lieu des accords
particuliers individualisé d'ailleurs
c'est la france a fait la promotion des
rescrit fiscaux comme la plupart des
états la france c'est aussi et donc ça
pose une question quand même sur
globalement dire est ce que devraient
être les polysons sur matière de
politique fiscale et s'agissant l'impôt
sur les sociétés moi je suis d'accord
avec vous c'est un impôt qui est
intelligent qui plus est quand on a des
difficultés on en déficit on en paye pas
donc ça tient compte quand même de la
capacité contributive des entreprises
mais se pose objectivement la question
vous l'avez dit de son adéquation que la
réalité économique voilà où se situe où
la création de valeur il doit y avoir un
prélèvement sur les bénéfices qui se
réaliser et toute la question de la
fraude 6 le détournement de stations ont
des places artificiellement de la valeur
pour faire l'objet d'une opposition au
royaume uni le gouvernement est passé à
la clé le 18 mars en créant une taxe de
25% sur les bénéfices des tournées des
gens du net
est-ce que ça c'est efficace ou pas jean
arthuis c'est une mesure possible mais
je vois bien comment les géants du net
s'ils prennent même avec la france
google vient à voir tel ministre de la
culture en lui expliquant qu'il a un
problème pour numériser les archives ou
je ne sais pas quoi
et immédiatement on sort le tapis rouge
et on peux tu imaginer ce qui se passe
derrière donc les gouvernements sont
pris dans l'instantané lors leur horizon
va rarement au delà de la prochaine
élection importante donc ont chacun
continuer à bricoler dans son coin
et voilà pourquoi on n'en sort pas donc
je pense qu'il serait intéressant voyez
vous que les députés je salue votre
investissement pour essayer de le
moraliser quand même
à noter mais ne croyez vous pas qu'on
aurait intérêt à travailler parlement
national et parlement européen pour
essayer d'influencer l'opinion publique
et de force et de chefs d'état et de
gouvernement à être plus audacieux dans
la construction européenne merci pour la
transition genre alors effectivement la
commune sur européenne a fait de la
lutte contre l'évasion et l'optimisation
fiscale une priorité absolue je cite
mais pour être efficace cette lutte va
devoir être collective est ce que c'est
possible on écoute à nouveau un extrait
du documentaire
si on a construit l'espace économique
européen
c'est pour permettre aux entreprises de
s'installer là où elles ont envie
s'installer pour toutes sortes de
raisons et notamment pour des raisons
fiscales
mais les chefs d'entreprise n'ont rien
contre l'impôt ils sont pas hostiles ans
soit un âge où la plupart des pilotes
aux crises sont des bons citoyens ils
sont particulièrement conscients des
problèmes de finances publiques est donc
tout à fait prêts à payer de la peau
c'est tout le monde paye le même impôt
si leurs concurrents payer leurs impôts
c'est ça le problème alors vous l'avez
dit précédemment la concurrence fiscale
c'est larmes numéro un des vols qui
nationalise c'est un obstacle
sachant que l'irlande ou le luxembourg
leur développement repose sur le dumping
fiscal si demain ils doivent mettre fin
à ces avantages les multinationales vont
faire un chantage et vont leur dire
d'aller ailleurs
en quoi ils ont intérêt à ce que demain
ils rejoignent une politique fiscale
globale
parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas et ne
peuvent pas espérer réussir durablement
dans une europe qui se disloque ray
l'europe telle qu'elle fonctionne
aujourd'hui donne aux populistes à
l'argumentaire extrêmement convaincant
tout ça parce que nos chefs d'état et
gouvernement sont timorés à l'égard de
l'europe
ils essaient de prolonger l'illusion
qu'ils auraient encore en mains des
prérogatives de souveraineté effective
et ils donnent en spectacle permanent
leur impuissance politique
donc ce n'est pas le repli sur soi qui
va nous permettre d'en sortir c'est au
contraire une vraie avancée un vrai
partage de souveraineté pour exercer
effectivement de souveraineté et c'est
vrai en matière fiscale
c'est vrai pour lutter contre la fraude
pour lutter contre les paradis fiscaux
un pays isolé ne peut rien faire si
l'europe décidé de pourrir la vie des
paradis fiscaux
elle y parle de le faire vincent drezet
oui sur la volonté politique enfin en
espérant qu aller dans le sens d'une
répartition équitable de la charge
fiscale
c'est avec un point important vous avez
tout à leur dîme sertic ont été de la
mondialisation une des problématiques
qui est posée c'est notamment la
question de l'aide au développement des
pays les plus pauvres qui subissent la
concurrence fiscale et sociale mondiale
on va le dire comme ça et là pour le
coup autant sur le luxembourg je doute
qu'ils aient besoin d'une aide au
développement réhaussée par contre il ya
un certain nombre de territoires au delà
d'une union européenne qui souffre de
l'activité des paradis fiscaux parfois
même de délinquance financière variés et
qui regarde aussi ce qui se passe du
côté des pays occidentaux bon pour faire
court notamment l'union européenne qui
va se passer notamment l'encontre des
paradis fiscaux est là pour le coup il
ya un enjeu pour empêcher le recours au
dumping d'un pic fiscales et sociales
notamment des pays en développement est
bien la question de l'aide au
développement est posée mieux voir une
et de développement ciblé si possible
efficace que le recours d'un pin qui est
finalement appauvrit les populations
alimente les paradis fiscaux il ya aussi
un enjeu global au delà de l'union
européenne chargée de l'aide au
développement pour être efficace ne peut
être qu'européenne sur ces questions là
et pour revenir sur ce que disait jean
arthuis a raison on a un vrai problème
de savoir ce que les gens attendent
certains pays attendent appartient à
européenne j'en prends juste un exemple
cas de l'irlande qui à l'automne 2008 en
pleine crise de subprimes a
littéralement été sauvé par la banque
centrale européenne corps effet
l'irlande
si à l'époque la banque centrale
européenne donc j'ai malgré tout notre
argent à tous
c'est pas un argent certes la banque
centrale européenne crée de l'argent
mais elle s'appuie quand même beaucoup
sur notre argent à nous qu aurait fait
l'irlande si elle n'avait pas fait
partie de cette solidarité fantastique
de 2008 qui lui a évité alors là
vraiment le crash dans une pauvreté
totale dans et pour autant à l'époque et
ça c'est dramatique mais l'union
européenne n'a pas exigé en retour sur
son âne modifié ailleurs ce qui conduit
repose beaucoup là dessus mais à
l'époque au moment où on est
on a sauvé hier l'irlande les banques
irlandaises on aurait dû dire mais en
échange les amis le taux à 12 % d'impôt
sur les sociétés ou l'oublier
et ça on ne l'a pas fait et c'est là
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit qu'on a un
problème politique c'est que on est prêt
à être solidaires ce qui est à mon avis
le grand enjeu de l'union européenne et
des cent prochaines années
on est très solidaire en cas de crise
pour certains pays qui dès qu'ils ne
bénéficient plus de 7 tev nous n'avons
plus besoin sont les premiers à rome
cette solidarité on peut pas continuer
très longtemps comme ça dont elle va
craquer giorgi est ce qu'on doit
envisager une harmonisation une
uniformisation des systèmes fiscaux est
ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer la
différence pour les téléspectateurs et
qu'elle est plus approprié il écoute et
une mise en convergence d'abord une
simplification de nos fiscalités chacun
est là en train d'imaginer une mesure
particulière
prenez les crédits d'impôt recherche par
exemple à tout le monde est d'accord
tout le monde est d'accord pour dire que
c'est formidable mais moyennant quoi ça
coûte quand même relativement cher et
comme les états n'ont plus d'argent de
crédit pour dépenses effectivement alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait on transforme ces
aides en avantages fiscaux comme ça ça
pèse moins optiquement dans la
présentation du budget mais on se
raconte des histoires en permanence donc
il faut plus de transparence plus de
simplicité la complexité fait
l'optimisation on a des taux élevés
parce qu'on dit comme ça aux citoyens
qui se fâche un peu écouté regardé on a
des taux élevés ont des courageux mais
derrière on vote tout un catalogue toute
une mosaïque toute une constellation
davantage dérogation dont kenny lingots
d'or en plus rien une âme en simplifiant
simply sion et faisons converger nos
lois fiscales aux lois sociales pour que
l'espace européen qui est un marché
unique puisse devenir un espace optimale
et qu'on n'est pas cette instabilité
permanente ces petits jeux stupides qui
sont des jeux de très court terme sont
dangereux l'entreprise valait pas si si
si si je ne donne pas ce avantage fiscal
elle ira chez mon voisin on est tous
perdants dans ce petit jeu là il s'agit
vraiment d'harmoniser
deux choses les taux ça tout le monde le
voit pas ce que c'est facile
d'harmoniser des taux passés facile
c'est pas facile mais mais le sujet
c'est l'harmonisation des assiettes ce
qu'on dit depuis le départ de la
discussion sur cette problématique de
niche d'évasion fiscale ce n'est que
pratiquement l'assiette qui jouent et
donc cette harmonisation des assiettes
qui est le lagon sur lequel sûr qu'on
bute depuis des années au niveau de l'ue
tentatives
oui mais on parle un sens que dans des
missions spécifiques en avant un système
supplémentaire que soit le système
européen
là on a on n'y arrive pas et tant qu'on
n'y arrive pas eh bien oui la plus
violente évasion fiscale a lieu à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne à
cause de ça lors d'un centre d'essai
visible dire simplement avoir une
fiscalité plus juste plus sain plus
simple et plus stable c'est nécessaire
c'est un peu le cas l'orientation
ensuite l'harmonisation les chantiers
sont les suivants l'impôt sur les
sociétés et la scène comme il consolide
imposerait société techniquement elle
est là et donc elle mériterait d'être
mise en oeuvre peut-être même avec un
engagement de ne plus baisser les taux
dans un premier temps la tva qui est
énormément fraude n en a pas trop parlé
mais 32 milliard d'euros n'ont rien que
pour la pour la france quelque chose
notamment pour la fraude carrousel
on a tout ce qui relève de litres de
lait de l'échangé d'informations sur
lequel elle y avance et on verra comment
comment ça se fait ce qui d'ailleurs
appelle la coopération et puis il ya un
enjeu qu'on oublie un peu mais restent
timides derrière on y met la fiscalité
numérique etc
derrière tous ces chantiers là mais il
ya également le budget européen qui a
finalement trop faible puisque le budget
européen
c'est aussi deux médailles et des
trophées mais on ne vote pas l'impôt au
petit plus est mais avec peut-être
pourquoi pas des emplois européens pour
l'alimenter et l'amour d'euros opaque
sur les transactions financières vous
dites voilà
écoutez je ris je la respecte vous
madame
si tout le monde l'appliquent c'est
d'ailleurs le texte était qu elle était
votée sous le gouvernement et majorité
socialiste c'est dans le code général
des impôts nous instituons une taxe
transactions financières et nous
l'appliquerons le jour où le monde
entier
la l'hypocrisie ce seront des éléments
de langage et c'est de cela que les
français ne veulent plus exactement et
nous terminerons sur ces mots merci à
tous ceux devenus sur ce plateau maxi
hamouda fidélité la semaine prochaine
laurent bazin vous proposera un
documentaire sur les grands discours de
la république française et moi je vous
retrouve dans 15 jours pendant
documentaire sur le recyclage du
plastique a très vite sur public sénat
fou